はい。それではこれから姿勢診断を行ってまいりますね。
はい。
で、今からお写真見ながらこうお体の体型や姿勢の癖を見ていきます。ちょっと専門用語が出てきて分かりにくいところなどあればその都何でもお聞きください。
はい。じゃ、まず正面のお写真から見ていきますね。ここではじゃあ太もの外腿も
内桃のお話をしていきます。
はい。
では、こちらのまずつ先と膝の向きに注目していただきたいんですけど、先ほどつ先えて外に向けていただいたのに対して膝は正面を向いてるのって分かりますか?
これも本来は同じ方向を向いてるのが理想的なんですね。
へえ。
で、これがどうなってるかって言うと、ここの股関節が今うちにねじれやすい状態になってるんですね。
で、それがねじれてしまうとこの太腿の
外側にある大天っていう骨が外に出っ張っ
てしまうので、その上から脂肪が乗って
しまったり、筋肉が張ってしまったり、
サイズアップしやすくなってきます。で、
あとはそのねじれにより、太ももこう内に
寄ってしまうので内腿が見えにくくなって
きます。うん。
で、さらにそれによってヒップ自体も股関節が内ねじれとお尻もこう外にぐーっと伸びてしまうので、本来の高さよりもちょっと下に下がりやすくなってくるんですね。
なんか色々とくるんですけど、ここまで大丈夫ですか?はい。
[笑い]
はい。
で、その状態になると、今原さんがどこの筋肉を使っていらっしゃるかって言うと、この外腿とヒップの外側を普段こう歩いてる時とか立ってる時に使ってらっしゃる状態ですね。うん。
で、逆にバランスで言うと今内側とヒップの真ん中辺内側があまり使えていない状態になってます。
はい。
なので、今角に使われてる外側の外腿、あとヒップの外側をしっかりほぐして伸ばしてあげる。で、逆にこの今使えていない内側の部分をしっかり刺激してトレーニングしてあげると下半身は
ヶ月ほどで足下半身全体がすっきりして綺麗な
lineラインが出来上がってきます。
へえ。はい。
ここまでは大丈夫ですか?
はい、大丈夫です。
はい。
では続いて横向きのお写真を見ながら次前も痩せとあとお腹痩せと上半身の姿勢の状態を見ていきますね。
ではまたこちらの膝のところに注目していただきたいんですけど、この膝がこう斜めにぐーっと伸びてしまってて、膝がちょっと下向いてるのってわかりますか?
はい。
この状態が専門用語で言う繁膝っていう状態になってます。
膝も本来ちょっと軽く曲がってるぐらいの方が理想的なんですけど、
今ちょっと伸び切ってしまってるので
はい。
えっと、普段立ってる時、歩いてる時どこ使ってるかって言うと、このふハぎと前も、あと腰を
ちょっと角に使っている状態になります。
はい。で、そうなるとどうなってくるかと
いうと、ふ、下半身がむみやすい状態に
なったり、前が張ってしまって、太もが
なかなか痩せにくかったり、あとは腰を
たくさんこう使っているので、ここの腰
が剃ることによって肋骨開い
たり閉じたりするんですけど、開き切る
状態で固まってしまってるんですね。へえ
。
なのでお腹が思ったよりもこう痩せ
にくかったりしてきます。
元々骨ってこう開いたり閉じたり呼吸と共にするのってご存知でした?
いや、知らないです。はい。[笑い]
本来はこう呼吸と共に動いてこう
閉じててるのが理想的なんですけど木原さんの場合はこう腰をたくさん使ってるのでこう閉じる力が今弱くなってます。
うん。
で、なんでたくさん使ってるこのふハぎ、前も、腰の代わりにあまり使えてないのが裏、お尻、お腹になってきます。
なんでたくさん使ってるところを伸ばしてあげる。
で、あまり使えてない裏腿、お尻、お腹を集中してトレーニングしてあげると下半身は同じく大体
4ヶ月、お腹はちょっと早く
ヶ月ほどで、えっと、全体的なすっきり感、ヒップアップもそうですし、綺麗な
LINEに整ってきます。
へえ。うん。
ここまでは大丈夫でしょうか?
はい、大丈夫です。
ありがとうございます。じゃ、最後姿勢の状態も見ていきますね。
はい、
次見ていただきたい。
この耳の位置と肩のトップのところ見ていただくと耳よりも肩が前に出てるのって分かりますか?
はい。
これがもうおっしゃっていただいた猫背巻き型のサインになってます。
うん。
これも本来は耳と肩の位置が同じぐらいに着てるのがいいんですけど、ちょっと前に出てますね。
はい。なんです。
なので肩が本来前に出てるのでどこの筋肉を使ってるかいうとやっぱりこの前側と力ぼを普段ぎゅっと固まって使ってる状態になります。
で、そうなるとこの背中二の腕の後ろがぐーっと伸び切ってしまうのでなので最近ちょっと背中二の脳が落ちにくくなったっていうのはその姿勢から来る要因にもなってます。
へえ。
そうなんです。なのでこの今縮まって
固まってるこの前側を伸ばして逆に今
伸び切ってしまってる背中にを
しっかりトレーニングしてあげるとお腹と
同じく背中二も同様人2ヶ月ほどでこう
姿勢が整い綺麗な体のバランスの状態に
なってきます。へえ。はい。こんな感じで
ここまでは大丈夫ですか?
はい。はい。ありがとうございます。
じゃあ、こう、全身見て今日いくつか姿勢の歪み癖があったので、ま、そこを元に今日はしっかりトレーニングをしていきますね。
はい。お願いします。
はい。